[Musique]
m me lance ont offert un petit voyage
dans le temps pour commencer en 1992
qu'est ce qui s'est passé au juste
qu'est ce que la cour suprême a dit
c'est intéressant parce qu'en 1992 la
construire modus prononcent ils déjà sur
la problématique des fausses nouvelles
bruit pourquoi c'est prévu par le code
criminel à l'époque c'est les gars
étaient illégales donc ces criminels à
l'époque de propager des fausses
nouvelles
c'est le cas d'un homme qui avait
propagé à un espèce de pamphlets si on
veut et ce qu'on en fera parler de
l'holocauste en niant l'holocauste
négationnisme ce négationniste
exactement donc c'est ce sur quoi la
cour suprême a dû se prononcer et la
question était de savoir est ce que la
liberté d'expression devrait primer ou
encore est-ce que contre on peut que se
conserver une certaine criminalisation
finalement de des fausses nouvelles la
cour suprême a statué que la clause du
code criminel qui interdit la
propagation de propos mensongers est
inconstitutionnelle parce que contraire
à la charte des droits et libertés
on voit bien que c'est une décision qui
était prise dans un contexte n'était
vraiment pas le nôtre
mais en 1992 ou en 2019 il ya une
question qui demeure la grande
difficulté c'est déterminé qu est ce qui
est vrai qu est ce qu il faut
exact il faut se questionner à savoir
qui va décider de quand est ce que la
vérité donc à ce moment là est ce que
des opinions qui sont minoritaires mais
qui pourrait se révéler vrai plus tard
vont à criminaliser et ne pourront plus
jamais sortir au grand jour
elle est un petit peu la problématique
on a l'impression que la cour suprême au
bout de huit ans 92 à l'époque en 92 on
n'avait pas d' intérêts légitimes du
législateur qui venait justifier une
interdiction plus importante de fausses
nouvelles
maintenant se pose la question c'est
dans un contexte où internet n'existait
à peu près pas qu'avec dans un contexte
y avait pas de médias sociaux
est-ce qu'on est à la même adresse
aujourd'hui est-ce que des mesures plus
limité pour venir visiter peut-être des
entreprises par exemple pour être prise
aujourd'hui il y en a des flexions et
d'avoir donc si on reste dans le
registre du civil par des recours très
concrètement la peau les gens qui nous
écoutent qui existe là leur portée au
niveau de la diffamation lorsque honda
font ces formations qui est propagée sur
soi la première chose c'est de réagir
relativement rapidement pourquoi quand
ça fait boule de neige si on est rendu à
100000 partage mais elle est au point
une action juridique sur terre qui peut
revenir dans le temps par contre nous on
a des moyens à notre portée qui existent
le premier c'est le plus simple c'est
tout simplement de signaler la
publication par l'entremise du média
social on pense par exemple à facebook
qui s'ouvre demain à juste relativement
rapidement danse
aussi lorsque c'est vraiment évident
qu'on a affaire à des dissonances
deuxième étape c'est d'appeler un bureau
d'avocats trop pour se renseigner pour
voir qu'est ce qu'on peut faire dans les
deux aussi les tribunaux je dirais pas
qu'ils sont mal lui aussi son lot 18,6
qui sont peut-être en décalage un petit
peu sauf que au niveau des injonctions
qui peuvent être prononcées par exemple
les mises en demeure ou s'ils peuvent
être envoyés le tout peut découler quand
même assez rapidement beaucoup d'eau
aussi qui se résorbent facilement
négocié qui explose c'est sûr ce sont
des codes espèces qui sont bien
distincts et puis on le sait ça c'est le
cadre légal actuel
mais des lois ça évolue exact
les lois pour les modifie donc entre
autres parce qu'elles doivent s'adapter
à l'évolution de la société aussi
qu'avec l'avènement d'internet les
médias traditionnels n'ont plus le
monopole de l'information n'importe qui
maintenant en quelques clics à peine peu
disséminés de l'information et parfois
défaut d'information alors est-ce qu'on
devrait pas autant criminaliser la
désinformation au canada
voilà son de 1,2 est-ce que les fausses
nouvelles devrait être illégal selon les
gens font disent condé de l'union avec
sa cb pas débrayer formation je constate
c'est que rec beaucoup déjà de famous
partout dans le monde
qu'est ce que vous croyez qu'il serait
temps de légiférer
je pense que oui c'est une très bonne
question c'est très difficile
non je dirais que je suis pas du tout
d'accord par rapport à ça c'est aussi un
moyen pour contrôler peut-être l'opinion
politique des gens je pense
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde a le droit
à la liberté d'expression jeu tout à
fait d'accord avec elle tout dépend du
sujet en fait des choses sur lesquelles
on ne peut pas violer évidemment les
deux choses sur lesquelles il faut
savoir sérieux mais bon pas forcément
maîtres de règles sur sa joie à tout le
moins que ça devienne moins important
est que bp alternatif on en est plus
faudrait le faire on le voit les avis
sont rapidement partagé sur cette
question mais ailleurs dans le monde
c'est une toute autre histoire
ouch pas si c'est pas illégale au canada
des fausses nouvelles dans certains pays
c'est carrément un criminel oui c'est ça
et le plus récent causé singapour qui
vient d'adopter une nouvelle loi cet
automne qui fait que les gens qui
partagent qui est jugé comme étant une
fausse information en ligne et ça peut
même être en messagerie privée ils
s'exposent à des amendes qui peuvent
aller jusqu'à 100 mille dollars et même
jusqu'à dix ans d'emprisonnement
donc cette tendance n'a on la voit dans
beaucoup d'autres pays en fait depuis
2018 il ya une dizaine de pays qui ont
adopté des lois du genre jusqu'aux
oreilles
c'est ce manque environ une dizaine et
on constate que ces pays là en fait
c'est souvent des pays qui sont très
loin d'être démocratique
mais voilà y ait toute vérité de mesures
est toujours le même souci la liberté
d'expression certains disent que souvent
ça devient liberticide de canton nestor
ce type de lois lane oui totalement
parce que officiellement ces lois elle
vise à arrêter la propagation de fausses
nouvelles
mais souvent le car s'est appliqué s'est
dirigée envers des journalistes des
opposants politiques ou encore des
militants pour les droits de la personne
qui critique le gouvernement donc
souvent le gouvernement qui tranche
entre ce qui est vrai et ce qui est faux
et on le voit par exemple en egypte il
ya en date de décembre dernier 19
journalistes qui étaient arrêtés par le
gouvernement pour avoir diffusé des
fausses nouvelles selon l'état on voit
par exemple en russie qui est aussi un
pays qui répriment beaucoup les
opposants politiques et la russie veut
créer une base de données des médias
qu'ils jugent comme étant des diffuseurs
de fausses nouvelles et ça va aussi
jusqu à restreindre des médias que le
gouvernement considère comme étant
irrespectueux envers le gouvernement
et puis un autre exemple assez flagrant
en thaïlande
il ya des gens qui ont été arrêtés pour
avoir leaké donc mis un j'aime sur
facebook à une publication qui était
jugée comme étant fausse morale de
l'histoire il faut se méfier de ce type
de mesures là quand on les voit
apparaître un peu partout dans le monde
si je comprends bien oui parce que
finalement on constate que ces mesures
là elles n'ont pas l'objectif qu'on
aurait pu souhaiter qui est donc de
restreindre la diffusion d'informations
fausses et néfaste l'objectif
ou le résultat c'est de museler les gens
qui pourraient être tentés de critiquer
le gouvernement
alors finalement ce qui est le plus
efficace pour contrer la propagation de
fausses informations
c'est l'éducation du public à
reconnaître la désinformation et aussi
permettre en fait la liberté
d'expression pour que les gens soient
exposés à des opinions contraires à des
opinions dissidentes et accès à une
opinion qui est transparente et non
seulement à l'opinion que le
gouvernement juge comme étant la bonne
mon nom là des motifs exacts
[Musique]